It's strange. The
good
thing about you was that you were serious and difficult to approach, but after you started dating Kazuya-kun, the number of
people around you suddenly increased. It's
not like that. Do
n't say it like it's a graveyard. It's different. It's time.  It's
just that I don't
have friends, so it looks like we'll have a lot of fun watching the movie together.Of
course I'm going to the screening, and it's finally finished.I'm
looking forward to it.Yes, Kazuya-kun worked hard to finish it.Of course, he's the
producer, so he
couldn't have gotten so many people involved and finished it.  That's not funny,
right? I think Kazuya-kun did his best,
but I
don't know about that, because he didn't even know how to use a camera at first.The
script didn't have any shape or form, and yet he
said he could definitely make it.
In the beginning, it was difficult to get permission from the people in charge of Kurafan, and
by the time I was so entrenched that I was barely
eating, so it would have been
easy for me to collapse at any time.After that, I wondered
what would have happened if I didn't have a neighbor.  I do
n't know, it's because they're reckless in the water over there, and there's no
crisis management in place.Listen,
even when the shooting stopped due to the sound of cicadas, I tried to
force them away and fell off the bridge, about 5 meters
below.The river is below.  It was a
good thing, but if it had been on the ground, I wouldn't have been seriously injured.On
top of that, I was drenched, and everyone was
worried about me, so I told them I needed to change
clothes, but the only clothes I had were women's
clothes, so I ended up going home in that person's women's clothes.Chizuruto.  I
know the moment when love blooms in someone. It's
when you talk happily about that person. It's
not like that.